[Music]
thank you
and then yours here we see Silicon
Valley characters setting up Wi-Fi
pineapples in a crowded Tech conference
room they made a fake hotspot to access
the free internet so that when they
connected they could stealthily download
their code into people's devices but
they were caught soon it was really easy
to notice these guys ah rookies in the
series the guys use a device known as
the pineapple it allows attacks on Wi-Fi
networks in our video we will talk about
how to defend against such attacks as
well as try to experiment with a
miniature analog of pineapple which we
assembled ourselves just to show you the
attack principles
[Music]
this video was created by the some
sub-verification platform but more about
some sub in a bit
[Music]
imagine that you need access to the
internet maybe you've gone to another
country you have no signal or just no
money you automatically turn on Wi-Fi
and suddenly notice a network with the
attractive name free Wi-Fi or the name
of the cafe where you're sitting what's
even more appealing is that the network
is open meaning it doesn't require a
password to connect you connect to it
suddenly the browser pops up with a nice
familiar window it's okay the user would
have thought and entered his data there
it's just end-to-end authentication a
lot of sites do that now
often sites offer to register with an
existing account it's easier for the
user because he doesn't need to remember
different passwords at this point a red
light on the device lights up and your
credentials are on the hackers device if
the hacker gets a password to for
example a Gmail account it's quite
possible that he will later gain access
to your other accounts via the password
recovery procedure such a small mistake
and your digital identity is at risk
twin is just one of the attacks that
pineapple type devices are capable of
we'll be sure to look into what happened
later
pineapple Wi-Fi attack is a popular form
of stealing one's identity however this
method has been around for years hi my
name is Lucas from Samsung and today I'm
going to let you know about our in-house
live Miss and defect detection
technology it enables companies to
detect criminals using defects the
system ensures that users are physically
present by creating a 3D face map of
them which is then continuously
referenced for authorizing their actions
going forward Linus technology is the
most secure solution in a world where
frankly passwords can be leaked and
phones can be hacked the solution uses
people friendly facial Biometrics that
work equally well all across the globe
it just takes two to four seconds to
authenticate users and complete the
check if you want to learn more about
our liveness technology check out the
link in the description below this way
you'll be able to prevent all of those
fake Tom cruises from attacking your
business
thank you
so in general Wi-Fi pineapple is a whole
series of devices based on Wi-Fi routers
or boards running a mips architecture
processor its main difference from the
usual router is a special firmware based
on open wrt which is packed with a lot
of ready-made popular utilities for
attacking Wi-Fi wrapped in a nice web
interface which is so attractive to
users pineapple does not have any
advanced i o tools a hacker is supposed
to control it remotely by connecting to
it via Wi-Fi from a phone while the
device lies in a backpack and
automatically performs attacks such an
intruder will hardly arouse people's
suspicions because it's just a phone and
a backpack there are a lot of Wi-Fi
attacks known today and we definitely
can't discuss all of them in one video
some of them must be performed in the
Dynamics moving and discovering new and
new targets but some of them are static
they work for a long time waiting for
certain events and we'll talk just about
a couple of these attacks these are
customer attacks such attacks often
involve leaving the Hacker's device in
an uncontrolled area for an extended
period of time which makes the Wi-Fi
pineapple a kind of consumable item and
it's not cheap at all an inexperienced
hacker will undoubtedly take the easy
way and buy a ready-made pineapple after
all now he will be able to hack his
neighbor without even understanding how
it works however once he loses such a
miracle device he may find out that it
will not be on sale or for example it
would take months to get this very
specific device into his country an
inexperienced hacker would sit and wait
but real hackers can easily assemble a
similar device and for less money in
fact in this era of abundant single ball
computers it's really easy to do this
some single board PCS can cost much less
than a pineapple single board PCS
designed specially for DIY are much more
amenable to modifications and
improvements than router-based devices
like pineapple on router-based devices
as a rule the memory is soldered
directly on the board and an effort is
needed to reflash the router whereas
single board PCS can be flashed easily
and without a soldering iron by
installing an SD card also a single
board PC runs on a more powerful arm
processor for which almost all the
software is ported in a convenient Dev
package that simplifies installation to
the maximum while for the mips
architecture many things must be
compiled and configured manually also
the variety of ready-made operating
systems for arm is much wider if the
pineapple is a ready-made solution out
of the box then your own device will
allow you to set it up flexibly for
different tasks because there is a lot
of Public Utilities available in
pineapple of course this requires some
knowledge but we are talking about
professional hackers
[Music]
the most successful solution may be the
Raspberry Pi 0w one of the few widely
known single board microcomputers whose
built-in Wi-Fi chips supports the
operating modes needed for the majority
of attacks the main feature of attacks
on both Wi-Fi and radio waves in general
is a limited range for Wi-Fi the limit
is 50 to 100 meters and the received
signal doesn't always allow the attacker
to take a comfortable place with a
laptop it's an ideal device for an
attack which can be placed unnoticed
near the targets and the hacker does not
risk being caught red-handed in addition
the miniature device is easier to hide
it can be hidden inside the parcel or
the Drone
in a past video with a drone a homemade
pineapple was used to perform radio
attacks on wireless mice the perpetrator
may not use external adapters with
massive antennas because the smaller
range of the built-in network card can
be easily compensated by the stealth of
the equipment and the ability to put it
closer to the targets let's analyze the
Hacker's actions step by step so that
you understand how such attacks work in
reality let's start with a detailed
inspection of the device
3.7 volt lithium battery and a voltage
boost board we get a minimal
configuration of our very own pineapple
the 3.7 volt battery on the bottom
supplies 5 volts to the second and Ninth
gpio pins via the mt3608 DC to DC Step
Up board
the voltage converter is also connected
with an external micro USB for
convenient battery charging and with a
toggle switch for battery power however
the raspberry has two USB ports of its
own which means one can always use a
regular power bank as well using a
display can be wasteful in terms of
saving battery power so three LEDs can
be used to indicate the process the LEDs
are controlled via the corresponding
commands of the raspberry zero OS for
example in order to light the LED solder
to pin 26 of the gpio the OS commands
are executed in the device
several jumper positions and two voltage
points 5 volt and 3.3 volt are used for
automatic starts of certain scenarios
also the 8th and 10th pins are the
points at which you can always open the
software shell on the pineapple device
using a uart adapter such an indication
is convenient because the hacker will
immediately see if someone is caught
before taking the hidden device away or
if it's worth coming back later further
in the familiar shell working with a
device OS you can make fine tuning of
the attack scenario
as you have already realized raspberry
can be turned into a multifunctional
attack device and we have done that by
writing the appropriate scripts for
security reasons we'll hide some parts
of the code because our goal is to show
the attack principles instead of giving
damaging advice so here we go to quickly
start the preset scripts we use a jumper
cross piece on gpio single board
computers like raspberry with gpios on
board can read the closure of certain
pins pairs it can be used as a simple
input device like a keyboard on software
side we monitor the Jumper's position
with a special command which is designed
to control the gpio supplying a small
power or reading the conductivity Now by
changing the Jumper's position and
shorting certain pins pairs just before
turning on the device the hacker
specifies the start of the desired
attack script parameters and cases of
their usage are set in the auto run
script the attacker's progress and
results are saved to the corresponding
files on the pineapple memory card with
the name reflecting the attack type time
and date just add this script to the
auto run
pineapple is not the only device capable
of attacking via radio and some attacks
are more appropriate for example from a
phone the form factor of the attack
device is ideal for covert prolonged
placement near the attacked objects and
the LEDs will inform about the attack
status without connecting to the board
let's go back to the evil twin attack
what happened there the startup.sh
script has the components that form this
attack the first component is the access
point it's script to start the access
point as soon as a client connects to
Pineapple the green LED lights up
configuration file template for an open
wireless network is the simplest the
configuration file specifies the network
name security type open network no
password and frequency Channel first in
this case the second component is a
script to start the DHCP server
the yellow LED indicates that the client
has obtained an IP address and has
started using this wireless network
proposed network configuration may be as
follows the configuration file specifies
the suggested network settings that
clients will automatically request via
DHCP this is the default behavior for
wireless networks the most basic things
are set here such as the range of IP
addresses for the clients the netmask
the Gateway and the DNS server the
raspberry device will act as the DNS
server in the last line we will set any
DNS request from a victim to the
pineapple IP this way absolutely all the
requests to any website will catch the
hacking device to make sure that no HTTP
request gets passed iptables will turn
back all web traffic from clients to
Pineapple at the network level the third
and most important attack part is a
small captive portal implemented via a
web server built into the PHP
interpreter this is probably the
simplest way to implement a web server
if the user enters a password pineapple
will notify you with a red LED
all requests are handled by the script
as a rule modern browsers send almost
nothing via open HTTP protocol and in
many browsers support of this protocol
is even deactivated but captive portal
is a common mechanism limiting access to
the internet from open wireless networks
so all modern operating systems
immediately after connecting check the
presence of captive portals by sending a
special HTTP request if at the moment
the attacked party is not informed of
the captive portal existence the attack
will fail if successful the system
automatically displays a phishing page
to the user sniffing out certain data it
was this page that tricked our
unfortunate user
[Music]
something similar to evil twin could
happen but with the aim already on the
client devices instead of the user's
devices suppose that the user in the
previous story connected to the wireless
network and saw the page asking him for
his mail password but he was smart
enough to conceal it however he did make
one mistake having connected to the
wireless network this means that an evil
hacker device can communicate with his
computer over the network it can start
arbitrary Network attacks given that the
victim's computer perceives pineapple as
a Gateway and forwards all its internet
traffic then in addition mitm attacks
can be developed however the hacker can
not only pass data between the victim
and the outer world but also change it
on the Fly redirecting to malicious
sites or injecting malicious code as
soon as the wireless network starts up
Global attack scripts are launched on
the device and as soon as a wireless
client with an IP address appears a
barrage of targeted attacks are
automatically started against it the
script starts attacks over and over
again for newly connected clients the
attacker can now automatically start any
computer attacks on the victim's device
maybe the victim just doesn't have a
strong enough password to log in if the
attacker's device picks it up it could
remotely install the back door and the
hacker can then remotely control that PC
the following script automatically
checks the password strength of all
connecting clients and if successful
runs a back door on them such a device
loaded with rce scripts can wait for its
victim for a very long time
[Music]
connection to the access point it means
that the defense against the
demonstrated attacks is simple just do
not connect to unfamiliar wireless
networks and certainly do not enter any
personal and confidential data there
speaking about evil twin it is a
classical example of Wireless fishing a
social attack which attacks the weakest
link the person there isn't any
technical protection against it except
your awareness consequently watching
this video is like installing a patch in
your head the second Vector was more
Technical and exploited bugs in your
computer software in fact you're not
immune to attacks on vulnerable software
on any other network but the solution is
simple just upgrade and use strong
passwords once again Samsung reminds you
to be vigilant in the wild online jungle
see you again in the next video
foreign
[Music]